[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining today.
Today, I'm really excited,
because we're announcing,
actually we just already
announced this morning, a
brand new part of the Google
Drive SDK called the Google
Drive Realtime API.
This is, I think, one of the
coolest APIs that we've done
in a while.
Definitely very forward
looking.
And for today's GDL, I want to
give you just a quick overview
of what the Realtime API is,
why it's important, to show
you a couple of the tools and
the samples that we've built.
But over the next few weeks,
we'll go into a lot more
detail on a lot of
these topics.
Next Friday, we'll show you how
to get started with the
API with our quick start.
Next week, we'll have one of
the engineers who actually
worked on the API join us for
some Q&A. And, of course, as
we hear more from the community,
we'll be back with
additional topics.
But today, we're going to focus
on an overview and some
quick demos.
But first, the Realtime
API is pretty simple.
It's a JavaScript API that
allows you to access a
persistent model that can be
manipulated by multiple users
in real time to give you the
same level of interactivity
and collaborations that you see
in our own applications
that are built around
Google Drive.
So Google Docs, spreadsheets,
presentations, are all well
known for the collaborative
features that are built into
the editors.
With this API, you can now build
other applications that
users need for productivity that
have that same level of
interactivity.
This really dovetails nicely
with some of the features that
we've been releasing over
the past few months.
Back in the fall, we added
commenting, of course sharing
has always been a
part of the API.
But when you throw all those
together, between sharing,
commenting, and real-time
collaboration, it's now very
possible and very easy to build
applications like Google
Docs at the same level of rich
interactivity, but can cover a
whole bunch of different
demands.
And we'll talk about some
of the use cases a
little bit later on.
First thing I just want to
show you is, if you are
interested in getting started
with the API, you can find the
documentation at
developers.googl
e.com/drive/realtime.
And there's a few different
things on here to
help you get started.
There's some quick start code.
This is a really simple
JavaScript application.
Some helper classes to make it
really easy to get started.
Of course the Developer's Guide
will introduce you to
all the different concepts
for working with it.
It's actually very simple if
you're familiar with standard
data structures like maps and
lists and adjacent objects
and, of course, you know
strings, you can build an app
using this API.
If you want to dive a little
bit more into it without
writing code, but get a feel for
how it works, what some of
the features are, what exactly
it means to have these type of
real-time features, we have the
Realtime API playground.
I'll show you that app
and walk through
it in just a moment.
And then, of course, you can
go and read more about it,
understand the event models,
and look at the source.
Lots of cool stuff.
So the first thing I want to
show you, actually, is a
really cool tool called the
Realtime API Playground.
This was developed by one
of the colleagues on
the DevRel team here.
It's a really cool app, and it
walks you through the process
of working with Realtime
Documents.
First thing you need to
understand is these are models
of documents that are stored
in Google Drive.
So you could think, just like
we have documents in
presentations and slides, we
can have other things.
So it could be images, they
can be project management
applications, they could be the
drawings, charts, videos
that we're editing, lots of
different things that people
want to work on together.
But these models, and all these
Realtime features are
geared around files in Drive.
First thing we need to do with
an app is authorize.
I've already done that, but this
is standard OAuth 2.0.
We've seen it all before.
It's in all our quick starts
and sample applications.
Next thing is we create
a document.
I've already done this, and we
can actually go back over to
Drive, and we can see a file
that I created earlier.
This is just the standard name
that the playground gives you.
Of course you could rename this,
share it, invite other
people to collaborate with us.
For right now, I'm
just going to
collaborate just with myself.
I have two different browsers
open, and we'll
see how that works.
Of course, if we have a file
that somebody shared with us,
we can open it.
This is just using our standard
JavaScript Picker API.
Of course, you can see the same
file is here, as well.
And if you want to share it,
you can do that, as well.
Again, this is the sharing
widget that has been part of
the Drive SDK for a while now.
So we have a file.
We've created it,
we've shared it.
In this case, I just have two
windows side by side here.
I'll switch back and forth just
to show you a little bit
of what's going on.
But the first thing is, let's
talk about some of the objects
that we can have in
the Realtime API.
Kind of the obvious
one is strings.
We have here a string
that we can do, and
this is really fun.
You can see, as I type,
we see all these
different events here.
And this actually character
by character.
Some of them are little bit
aggregated, depending on how
fast I type, but we see what
is actually being sent.
So these events, the way it
works, this is based on
operational transform.
So as we type and make changes
to the model or strings or
objects within it, the
API is figuring out
what exactly changed.
So if it's a string, if it's a
character insertion, it will
generate insert x, y,
z at this position.
Likewise, if we delete and then
re-insert, we'll see a
delete event followed
by the inserts.
So all these deltas are being
applied locally and then sent
back to be applied to the
persistent model.
If somebody else is
making changes,
those changes are resolved.
They're reordered so everything
makes sense, and
then rebroadcast out.
You can see over here, in this
other window, that string has
been updated.
And if you actually watch, we
have both of these visible
here, so as I type, you
can see there's a
little bit of lag.
It's probably a few hundred
milliseconds.
But as I type, you can see in
the background window, that
text is being updated.
Strings are the first one.
Strings are particularly
interesting because there are
some additional behaviors
that are pretty
important for usability.
Particularly the issue
of cursor management.
So I'm not entirely sure if this
has been implemented in
here, but--
it's a little hard to show with
just one browser, but I
have my cursor here right before
the N. And if I go and
delete, let's say,
delete really.
OK, so this is actually a case
of why, so it's actually good
that I showed this.
So you notice that
my cursor moved.
It didn't actually
change position.
Actually, where the position
is is the offset, but not
logically in the string
where I'm at.
Really I wanted my cursor
to stay at neat.
Part of the API is a set of
utilities to help manage
cursor position as these
events happen.
So you can implement
this yourself.
You can sit there and listen for
string events, and detect
when a character is added or
a character is deleted, and
figure out where your
cursor should be.
But part of the API is
a set of binders.
These are really
simple things.
You can just say, connect this
string to this text field, and
we'll actually do some
of that for you.
It' s something I've actually
implemented in the Realtime
Playground.
It's something that we'll
add so you can see
just how that works.
But beyond strings, of course,
we have collections.
Obvious one are lists.
You can see here.
Scroll down.
Keep that visible in
the background.
And let's add lemurs,
I like lemurs.
You can see that was
added to the list.
I also like sloths.
I think they're ridiculously
cute.
You can see these added.
Likewise, you can come back
up here and remove sheep.
Again, you could see that's
been removed.
You can see the event up here.
So we had events that we added,
things that were removed.
You could do the same thing
for Maps, as well.
And we can see down here.
And the last thing, which is
actually kind of cool is, if
you don't like working with
generic collections, you can
define your own objects.
So here we have, you can even
see the source code.
So our key value pairs, if you
jump directly to the source,
actually even better than
the source, let's
just show the Docs.
Let's go to Developers' Guide,
and Building a Data Model.
So you can have code in your
application that basically
looks like this.
You can define objects, you
can tell us about the
different properties on your
object that are persistent and
should be collaborative.
And then once you have those,
you just access these just
like a regular JavaScript
object.
Turns out to be really,
really simple.
Sorry for zooming in a
little too far there.
But you can actually see
here how this is done.
We create a constructor, just
like we would normally.
We do need to register this
type so that you know how
these things should be stored.
The API is designed so you can
evolve your models over time.
So there are symbolic names
for all your types and for
your properties.
Clearing our fields, create, add
some listeners if we want
to track changes, and,
of course, just
deal with our property.
Really simple.
The nice thing with the Realtime
Playground is, well
besides just giving you a good
idea of how things work and
letting you see the events, you
can actually open up the
Chrome dev tools, you can watch
the wire traffic, just
to get a sense of what the
payloads look like as they're
being sent across the wire.
But the cool thing is, for each
of these, you can go back
to the reference docs.
For this feature, talk about
strings, talk about lists.
And the source code
is available for
this, as well on GitHub.
Go to GitHub.com/googledrive
and see the Realtime
Playground source.
There's also another example
out, which I
think is really cool.
It is a Realtime collaborative
3-D cube.
Again, I'm not really
collaborating with anyone in
particular right now.
Let me make it visible.
So now, what we do is we can
start to mess up our cube, and
you can see, as I turn this in
one, you can see the changes
reflected here.
And likewise, if I go over here,
everything is mirrored
in the other one.
And, of course, you can
have this with as many
collaborators, as well.
If you have four or
five people in
there, that's just fine.
And you can see this in the
app here, this list of
collaborators, and the same
thing here in the Realtime API
Playground.
So this is actually something
that is built into the API,
the notion of collaborators.
We can actually see
what happens if I
exit out of this document.
We're going to see I dropped
off from this window.
And we actually see an event,
user closed the document.
I can now go back and rejoin,
and pretty soon we're going to
see user opened.
So it's a great way, if you want
to have presence built
into your application, you just
subscribe for those events.
We'll tell you any
time that another
user joins that session.
Or if they leave, and you can,
of course, render this.
And even things like the profile
photos of the users
are available as part of the
API, along with the name of
the person that you're
collaborating with.
So you can build some really
cool, very, very interactive
collaborative applications
with this.
And we worked with a couple of
external developers to build
some proof of concepts
of this.
If you've seen today's my blog
post, there are three apps
that are mentioned, which we're
talking about briefly.
The first is Gantter.
Gantter is a project management
application.
It lets you build Gantt
charts, set up
your project plans.
They've updated their
application so that it has the
same sort of real-time
collaboration features that
you've seen here.
So, yeah, if you change the due
date of a project, anyone
who's in there and updating
their tasks will see
everyone's changes pretty
much immediately.
Again, the latency with this
is actually really,
surprisingly good.
Only a few hundred
milliseconds.
Basically the same that you
would see within Google Docs
or Slides or Sheets.
So, Gantter.
A very cool app.
Definitely encourage people
to check it out.
The other is draw.io.
This is a technology demo from
the people who do Jgraph.
They do a graphing library.
But they have this really cool
charting application.
It lets you build everything
from flow charts, electrical
diagrams, to mock-ups.
A very, very large template
library of shapes.
And, again, they've been enabled
real-time features so
now you can store those drawings
in Drive in a way
that is persistent.
So that when people are in the
diagram drawing, if I move a
shape or I add a shape, you'll
actually see that.
Other collaborators will
see those happen.
They actually do some really
interesting things around
visual clues to let you know
when a collaborator did
something, and certain things
like flashing a border around
a shape that was moved by a
collaborator, and they match
the colors with the
collaborators.
Up here we can see
them both green.
Really cool thing.
Really good use of visual
clues there.
Gantter also does some really
interesting things.
Going back a brief moment for
Gantter, they do some
interesting things with bolding,
integrated chat into
their application using the
Realtime API, in addition to
having the model.
And then the last one I want to
mention is Neutron Drive.
This is an online IDE that is
backed by Google Drive.
So you can use it for
editing text files.
You can also use it for
editing source.
And they're doing some cool
things in that they're
actually letting you
work in multiple
documents at the same time.
It's a really cool app.
It kind of fills a void in
Google Drive in terms of just
working with source code or
working with plain text files.
And one thing really important
about Neutron Drive is they
actually do some really cool
stuff with syncing the
Realtime model.
So the representation of the
file in a way that we can do
these operational transforms
on, and then syncing those
changes back to the underlying
text file, so that if you have
the sync client installed and
you're having those files
copied down to your desktop,
maybe you're using an IDE for
when you're offline, all that
works pretty seamlessly.
There are a number of issues
that come up when you try to
do these types of things.
But there's actually some really
good resources in the
SDK documentation that talks
about this, particularly using
collaborative models
with files.
Talks about some of the issues
that happens when you want to
work with some sort of external,
serialized format,
say an image, or a text
file, Visio diagrams,
whatever that may be.
Trying to enable collaborative
features on these is a little
bit more complicated than
if you were a purely
collaborative app, something
like Google Docs, for example,
but it is possible.
Just read through
these guides.
We'll actually probably have
another GDL to go into this
topic in particular.
There's a lot of things to talk
about here, but I don't
want to go into too
much detail today.
But really just, for now, just
want to give you a taste of
what the API is about, to show
off some of the demos, and
that's about it.
Really, for the past couple
months I've been playing
around, doing a couple
sample apps that I'll
be adding to GitHub.
It is an incredibly fun
API to play with.
It is highly satisfying,
primarily because you don't
have to worry about
all that much.
So a lot of the applications
have been building, have been
pure JavaScript applications,
not even using a server.
I mean, technically, you could
serve your application out of
Google Drive using the
ability to serve
directories as resources.
It doesn't require a server.
Authentication is, use
your Google account.
You can take advantage
of things like
the new Google+ Sign-In.
The files themselves, the data,
is persisted in Drive.
So I create a file in Drive, I
attach a Realtime model to it,
and then I just work with that
as if it were just a local
data structure memory.
And it's persistent.
I can close the browser, come
back three days later, open
the file from Drive, and I'm
exactly where I left off.
If other people were in there
making changes, I see all
those changes.
Doing things like [? presence ?]
are incredibly
easy, and you saw with the
Realtime API Playground, how
you can add things like sharing
and the file picker
and everything.
You can build these really
powerful apps just with
JavaScript and HTML5 and not
have to worry about scaling,
you don't have to worry
about your servers.
Really, the only thing you need
to be able to do is serve
some HTML and JavaScript and
whatever assets you need for
your application.
And you're good to go.
It's really powerful.
I'm incredibly excited to see
what people start to build
with this API.
It does open up a whole bunch
of different use cases.
Certainly with Docs, we're very
proud of the applications
that we have.
We cover a lot of the core
productivity applications, but
there's a whole bunch of
applications that people need
to do their jobs on a
day-to-day basis.
We're not going to build all
of them, but many of them
would benefit from having
real-time collaboration like
we've seen from draw.io, and
Gantter, and Neutron Drive.
These are all really useful
applications that benefit from
real-time collaboration, but I
would love to see things like
collaborative video editing,
or audio editing, different
charting applications, drawing
specialized editors for
different cases.
If you like to author scripts.
I know there's some great web
apps out there to help people
do that, that could be made
collaborative, as well.
Really, just about anything.
If you work with documents, the
Realtime API is definitely
something to check out.
That is, I think, all
I want to cover
today for the overview.
Again, we're going to be back
to talk about this and a
couple of topics I mentioned
earlier.
On Friday, we'll be talking
about the Quick Start.
I'll just give you a quick
overview of it.
I'm not going to go into a lot
of detail, but really it takes
about five minutes to get this
set up and you can start to
play with it, learn how
to use the code.
You can see here, it's all about
100 lines of HTML and
JavaScript.
So Friday, we'll be back, we'll
go into this in a lot
more detail, show you how you
can take the Quick Start,
modify it a little bit to start
exploring some of the
other features.
We'll be back again next Tuesday
with Brian [? Carns ?]
who's one of the engineers
who worked on this API.
And we'll have a chat
with him, go
through some questions.
So that should be really
great session.
And, of course, there's a whole
bunch of other things
that we can talk about.
If there's particular things
that you would like to know
about the Realtime API, join us
in our Google+ Community.
Go to Google Drive Developers,
post questions there.
We will respond to them in the
community, but they will also
help us determine what we're
going to talk about Brian and
in future GDLs about this.
If you have ideas for what
you would like to
build, let us know.
Again, I'm really excited.
I think this opens up a whole
bunch of new opportunities for
developers to build really
powerful, really amazing
applications.
So let us know if you have an
idea, what you're working on,
if you have any questions,
we're here to help.
Other than that, I'm
very excited.
I have a whole bunch of ideas
for my own, of sample apps
that I want to do.
So we'll keep updating
our repositories, so
keep an eye on that.
If you use Angular, I've been
playing a lot with that.
Angular is nearly magical.
It's actually a really
beautiful development
experience.
So we'll see some samples
there, as well.
But really, just go out
and try the API.
It's really fun, really
satisfying, and, of course, we
look forward to seeing
what everyone builds.
So on that note, I'm going to
end today's GDL, but again,
reach us in the community.
If you have questions, comments,
ideas, we'd love to
hear from you.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]